foreign
comes from Jessie in the baby steps
millionaire group he says I'm 61 years
old I'm hoping to retire soon but
watching my retirement savings go down
day after day after day the only part
not going down is a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars sitting in the bank
earning almost zero interest but not
completely eroding away with the stock
market what should I do who I like this
question
um
for many reasons number one
Jesse
um you're forgetting that the money
that's just sitting in the bank it you
know you're not it's not earning
interest like it would in the stock
market but there is a little thing
called inflation
and that is affecting your savings
that's just sitting there so I'm just
putting that out there but let's talk
about this retirement savings because
you're telling me that it's quote
completely eroding away and that's
that's just not true bull yeah that's
just not true the stock market is
down but it's not completely eroding
away and it will come back up we know
that we you can look at the track record
and know that this is temporary the
stock market is cyclical it goes down
and it goes up so
Jesse one of the things you have to
understand and it helped me because I
actually got into the research about 30
years ago on this is that uh we all
especially when it comes to investing
but a lot of other things too we all
have a drama queen that lives in our
brain
that exaggerates everything and oh God
you know thing okay and uh
that
the studies have told us now that it
takes three dollars of gain in an
investment to emotionally offset one
dollar of loss
our brain records negative things
at a much greater rate
and it takes a while it takes a lot of
emotion to recover from that and so what
I'm saying is is that Jade is exactly
right your drama queen wrote this email
okay completely eroding away oh ball
look okay it's down maybe 10 but I mean
so if you got a million dollars now it's
worth nine hundred thousand and next
year it'll be worth a million three I
mean I mean me and one I mean whatever
it's just so it's not completely eroding
away so because Jesse here's another way
of knowing that have you ever heard
people say this I lost all my money in
the stock market mathematically
impossible
it just didn't happen you didn't lose
all your money in the stock market
unless you put it all in one company and
that company completely closed yeah
and was worth zero if you put all your
money in Enron
you lost all your money in the stock
market certain cryptocurrencies yeah
well that's probably even the stock
market right that's true you know but it
would have but but you know but what
people really mean is I lost a bunch of
money I freaked out I went into hyper
drama mode I pulled my money out at
exactly the wrong time while it was down
and then bitched about it for the next
decade that's what we really mean when
you say I lost all my money and stuff
you didn't lose all your money in stock
market so in 2008 the market went from
000 out of 6500 went in half
and the number of people that will tell
you they lost everything in the stock
market in 2008 is amazing because and
they're all wrong you just didn't you if
you had if you put it in at 13 and with
6 500 you have the world's worst
possible timing you pulled it out at the
bottom and if you did that you lost the
most you could have possibly lost in
recent memory right in 100 years almost
not a hundred but eighty yeah 80 years
okay and um and even in that event you
only lost half your money that's right
you put a hundred thousand in and went
to 6500 worth 50 Grand and by the way I
put money in at 13. I didn't take it out
at all and guess what the 6500 is worth
now it's a 38 000 right and so you know
five if you so if you had a million at
the bottom you got five or six million
now wow you just you got to look in the
mirror and tell yourself the truth I got
to tell this story my my son this is
exactly what this reminds me of uh my
son is five and I do his hair for him
every morning because he's got curly
hair and I have to spray it down with
water and he hates that and today I have
to do that do you to just keep the shine
going
Dave a little drip of water drips from
his hair like onto a shirt and he's like
look at me I've got water all low for me
yeah yeah that's it and I'm like you
have one drip of water on your shirt and
I made him look I said look in the
mirror and say there's not water all
over me there's water there's a drip of
water on my shirt and he said he set it
in the mirror and then I said and now
now say
spraying water on my hair is part of the
process and sometimes water gets on my
shirt and he said it and I think that's
what this is you got to know when you
invest in the stock market
part of the process is it goes up and it
goes down and you're not completely
eroding and getting I'm completely
drenched you gotta Dr it drips all right
like you gotta look sometimes you just
gotta tell yourself the truth and just
accept it facts and Mathematics are your
friends to tell your drama queen and all
of us have one and so we have to do that
we have to do the facts to tell our
drama queen to shut up yeah we're going
to continue to invest and no I'm not got
180 000 sitting in the bank wondering
why it's not going up because I know
it's not gonna that ain't doing I'm not
doing squats he's tripping he thinks
that money's doing well that's losing
value too right now that's just every
single down year in the stock market's
history but one is followed by a record
two-year rise
wow so if you're out right now
historically
you're stupid
that's what history that's not good
hysterically historically ah there's a
difference right there you need to use
history not hysteria and that's the
thing because Jesse all of us do this
the other one that goes with Jesse's
thing here that I run into and I run
into this sometimes when we're doing a
media appearance too is what are retired
people going to do this stock market is
down how are they going to live well
they weren't going to cash all their
money out this year anyway right right
if you've got a half million dollars in
your 401k you're not going to run over
and cash it out this year unless you
panic and you probably weren't planning
to cash it out you're probably just
going to live off of the income that it
creates and not even touch the principle
well that's so let the principal ride
the roller coaster and just let your
income a reasonable income come off of
it and retired people are just fine that
way but broke people when they retire
they don't have fun even in up markets
that's true that's true because you
never had it to begin with now Jesse you
said that you're still working you
haven't retired yet so keep investing
now is a great time to buy get the 180
000 invested right now dude I don't time
the market but I'm telling you every
down Market bear Market that it holds
out as long as this one has held out is
followed by a two-year upturn that's
good to know except one every single one
of them what was the exception do you
know
no not off the top of my head I was
looking at the charts the other day it
might have been 08.
well it might have taken it more than
two years to recover it might have been
I think there were two down years in a
row there and that's what throws that
number off if I remember right but I
mean you go back and look where we've
had because usually what happens too
around this is election cycle that's a
very good so think about what the
election cycle is by this time next year
we are sick of presidential
by this time next year you're going to
be so sick of politics because you're
going to be right Square in the middle
of a booming presidential election and
guess what that does to the stock market
hello it gives it hope that's true and
hope is all the stock market needs to go
up and so just just hang on when when
the leaves get green next spring
all these companies out there are not
losing money they're all making money
guess where stock price comes from
profit and potential profit and
projected and forecasted profit and
that's all still there